et notre invité ce matin pour cette
émission spéciale décision du Conseil
constitutionnel c'est de microusseau
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
constitutionnalisme professeur de droit
public à l'Université Paris 1 Panthéon
Sorbonne on va évidemment parler de
cette décision avec vous d'abord je vais
vous demander Dominique Rousseau votre
avis quel est selon vous la décision la
plus probable ce soir
constitutionnel je suis pas la petite
souris qui écouterait aux portes ou sous
le plancher non je n'en sais rien en
tant que juriste c'est vrai que je
dirais que objectivement il y a des
grillés d'inconstitutionnalités sérieux
qui pourrait je dirais pas qui devra
mais qui pourrait conduire à
l'annulation totale de total de la loi
ecoutez le principal c'est d'avoir
choisi l'article 47 pour faire cette
réforme c'est à dire d'avoir choisi la
voix d'une loi de financement
significative de la sécurité sociale
alors que le contenu de la loi actuelle
porte sur les principes fondamentaux
d'un régime de retraite or l'article 34
excusez-moi de le faire la technique
mais l'article
34 dit la loi détermine les principes
fondamentaux de du droit du travail et
de la sécurité sociale or fixer l'âge de
la retraite c'est un principe
fondamental supprimer les régimes
sociaux c'est l'organisation des
principes fondamentaux d'un régime de
retraite la pénibilité c'est un principe
fondamental la question des des
carrières hachées notamment pour les
femmes ça fait partie des principes
fondamentaux d'un régime de retraite
autrement dit le véhicule législatif
comme comme vous dites moi je dirais la
voix procédurale choisie pour cette
réforme n'est pas la bonne je rappelle
d'ailleurs que le
féministe Edouard Philippe en 2019 avait
choisi la loi ordinaire pour réformer
les retraites par point
marison Touraine el khomri et Eric verte
toutes les réformes du régime des
principes du régime des retraites c'est
fait par la loi ordinaire là le
gouvernement a pris la voix de l'article
47 c'est-à-dire les lois de financement
rectificatives or c'est pas fait pour ça
la loi de financement rectificative de
la sécurité sociale c'est fait pour
modifier le cas échéant les objectifs de
dépenses de la sécurité sociale là c'est
pour définir les principes pérennes du
régime des retraites 64 suppression des
régimes spéciaux etc donc il y a une
erreur si vous voulez de procédure
pour vous serez de nature à aller
jusqu'à la censure totale parce que vous
allez nous le dire mais la censure
totale d'un texte c'est quand même
extrêmement rare et encore plus un texte
budgétaire alors c'est rare je dirais
heureusement heureusement que les
gouvernements ne font pas d'erreurs de
procédures sinon ça serait grave pour
notre démocratie mais ça s'est vu
l'exemple le plus célèbre c'est en 1979
lorsque le Conseil a censuré justement
une loi de finances de l'année une loi
de pas de financement de la sécurité
sociale mais le budget de la nation qui
a été censuré dans sa totalité en
décembre 1979 et pour quel motif un
motif de procédure donc le Conseil
constitutionnel a déjà fait tomber la
totalité d'une loi pour un conduit un
détournement de procédure un défaut de
de procédure d'élaboration de la loi
pourquoi parce
que ce matin
sur total qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
est-ce que ça veut dire que le texte va
la poubelle ou est-ce que ça veut dire
que le texte peut être repris tel quel
mais via une loi ordinaire alors non non
ça veut dire si si la loi est annulée
totalement ça veut dire que le Président
de la République ne peut pas promulguer
la loi
il ne peut pas prendre une guidelwa donc
changeant de véhicules législatif
c'est-à-dire on repart à zéro et
un nouveau débat à partir de sur le
fondement de l'article 34 s'engage avec
vraisemblablement l'application de la
loi à l'archet c'est-à-dire l'obligation
de négocier avec les organisations
syndicales le régime des retraites alors
ce que c'est 62 63 60 65 bon après
négociation à hauterne des négociations
un débat parlementaires la loi ordinaire
comme comme il avait fait avec Édouard
Philippe le débat normal donc si
l'empêche de reprendre le texte tel quel
il faut juste changer de voix de voix
législative de véhicules législatif oui
parce que le Conseil le conseil ne se
sera pas prononcé ne se serait pas
prononcé sur le fond de la loi mais sur
la voie c'est ce qu'on appelle si vous
voulez c'est ce que les lingerie on
appelle les le rôle d'aiguilleur du
Conseil constitutionnel en gros le
Conseil dirait écoutez vous pouvez
passer de 62 à 64 mais pas par cette
voix vous êtes trompé de voir c'est pas
l'article 47 qu'il fallait prendre c'est
l'article 34 et maintenant vous vous
recommencez le débat l'autre scénario
possible c'est une censure partielle
qu'est-ce qu'il pourrait justifier pour
vous une censure partielle alors ce qui
pourrait justifier le une censure
partielle et qui va être un peu dans le
sens de ce que je viens de dire c'est
qui dans le dans la loi actuelle qui a
été adopté par le Parlement il y a
beaucoup de dispositions qui n'ont pas
un objet financier or dans une loi de
financement il faut qu'il y ait que des
articles est un objet financier logique
or il y a un certain nombre de
dispositions par exemple l'indique
l'index Seigneur par exemple le CDI
Seigneur par exemple les carrières
hachées pour les femmes
tout ça ce sont des dispositions qui
n'ont pas un objet financier direct et
le Conseil constitutionnel pourrait
considérer qu'il s'agit selon
l'expression consacrée de cavalier et
donc sortir les cavaliers du texte et
censurer partiellement en quelque sorte
la loi ce qui fait qu'il ne resterait
que le passage de 62 à 64 je vous dis
pas les conséquences de cette censure
partielle d'articles qui ont été faits
pour comment dire adoucir le passage de
62 64 c'est à dire que c'est une loi
plus dure
uniquement les cavaliers et les
cavaliers évidemment il resterait le
cœur du réacteur c'est-à-dire le passage
de 62 à 67
et la même question que tout à l'heure
ça veut dire que dans ces cas-là
Emmanuel Macron peut dès demain dès ce
soir promulguer la loi sans ce qui a été
censuré absolument donc il peut
promulguer si la loi n'est pas censurée
dans sa totalité le prénom République
promulgue la loi et peut demander à ce
que les cavaliers qui auraient été
sortis de la loi soit repris dans une
loi ordinaire ce qui ce qui renforce
encore cette idée que cette réforme des
retraites aurait dû être fait par la
voix de la loi ordinaire la petite 34 et
non pas par la voie verticale7 le
Conseil constitutionnel peut aussi
valider totalement la réforme ça ça vous
paraît possible ça
non non je pense que il y aura au
minimum une censure des annulation des
articles qui ont un objet non
directement financier on dit souvent du
Conseil constitutionnel et c'est son
rôle qu'il juge en droit qu'il ne juge
pas sur le fond est-ce que dans un cas
comme celui-là il peut juger en droit
rien qu'en droit
[Musique]
il est fait pour ça le Conseil
constitutionnel doit fonder et motiver
ces décisions en droit
en revanche et je sens ce qu'il y avait
derrière votre question le Conseil
constitutionnel comme tout juridiction
[Musique]
produit des décisions fondées en droit
mais qui ont des effets politiques mais
pas que le conseil quand par exemple le
Conseil d'État
annule ou censure le gouvernement parce
qu'il n'a pas respecté les accords de
Paris sur la diminution du réchauffement
climatique c'est une décision fondée en
droit l'accord de Paris n'a pas été
respecté mais évidemment ça a des
conséquences politiques toute décision
de justice fondée en droit à des
conséquences politiques alors le
problème c'est que souvent on fait un
raccourci puisque ça a des conséquences
politiques c'est une décision politique
non c'est une décision fondée en droit
et qui a des conséquences politiques
est-ce qu'il peut vraiment s'abstenir du
contexte politique ils sont pas coupés
du monde c'est il voit très bien ce qui
se passe dans la rue il va très bien ce
qui se passe dans le pays ça joue dans
leur décision forcément bien sûr le
Conseil constitutionnel prend en
considération les conséquences possibles
de sa décision et évidemment
comment dire l'appréciation des
conséquences possibles d'une décision de
de justice que ce soit administratif
civil ou constitutionnelle sont toujours
très très délicates on pourrait par
exemple considérer que la conséquence
politique
d'une annulation totale de la loi
la conséquence politique soit
le l'apaisement social si le Conseil dit
la loi est annulée totalement et bien
plus de manifestation
les manifestations tombent puisqu'il y a
plus de réseau de manifester puis il y a
plus de doigts et on repart à zéro et
l'intersyndicale pourrait dire bon ben
très bien on repart à zéro on rentre
dans la négociation puisque cette loi
concestait et est tombée alors
évidemment la conséquence politique
c'est que peut-être le président de la
République serait pas content que sa loi
soit retoquée pour des des régions de
procédures maintenant il pourrait dire
aussi écouter c'est pas de ma faute
c'est les jus ils sont méchants ils ont
pas voulu que etc mais ça serait quand
même si je j'entends un peu ce qui se
dit dans la majorité présidentielle
cette porte de sortie ne serait pas pour
déplaire y compris au sénateur et
députés de la majorité actuelle on va
revenir
là qui a marqué hier le Conseil
constitutionnel protégé par des dizaines
de forces de l'ordre pour éviter des
violences et d'éventuelles intrusions
est-ce que c'est une absence de sérénité
qui peut jouer sur la décision des sages
non non non non non je crois qu'ils
le Conseil changerait ou modifierait sa
décision parce que il serait davantage
protégé qu'il y aurait un risque de
d'envahissement des des du conseil
aussi aujourd'hui pour lui-même pour
l'institution vous avez raison de poser
la question ça fait partie des
conséquences je pense que le une
annulation totale de la loi aurait une
force de légitimation supplémentaire du
Conseil constitutionnel le Conseil
constitutionnel est souvent à mon avis
trop souvent
critiqué certains même souhaiteraient le
supprimer ou diminuer son rôle soit
parce que il est trop près du
gouvernement soit par et je pense que le
Conseil constitutionnel en annulant la
loi se poserait
comme le gardien des droits du Parlement
Sénat Assemblée nationale comme le
gardien d'un équilibre des pouvoirs
comme le gardien d'une forme de
démocratie qui associe la démocratie
sociale qui a manqué
avec la démocratie
parlementaire juste pour
qu'on comprenne des droits du Parlement
parce que le Sénat a voté cette loi
le Sénat a voté cette loi vous me
rappelez dans quelles conditions alors
utilisation de l'article 38 du Règlement
c'est-à-dire l'imitation du débat à un
orateur pour un oracteur compte
utilisation de l'article 44 le vote
bloqué tous les amendements tombent sauf
le les amendements retenus par le
par le gouvernement donc il suffit il
suffisait de suivre les débats sur votre
chaîne pour voir que le les tous les
sénateurs y compris d'ailleurs ce de la
maturité trouvait que le temps du débat
et la manière dont le débat s'est passé
disons avait malmené le principe de
clarté et de sincérité des
débats au Parlement oui oui
mais encore une fois pour moi
c'est factuel c'est à dire si vous lisez
ou si vous écoutez les débats
parlementaires que ça soit l'Assemblée
nationale ou au Sénat vous avez bien vu
qu'il y a eu souvent une confusion il y
a eu des éléments qui manquaient pour
des députés les sénateurs pour se faire
une idée de par exemple sur le sur la
motivation
alors certains ministres disaient la
motivation c'est pour rééquilibrer le
déficit du régime des retraites d'autres
disaient non non c'est pour dégager de
l'argent pour assurer les
investissements de la transition
écologique alors pourquoi on fait la
réforme donc il y a eu une
comment dire une confusion parfois dans
les régions pour lesquelles cette
réforme était lancé uniquement à aux
modalités du débat c'est pas lié aussi à
une volonté d'une partie des oppositions
de ralentir ce débat et d'empêcher qu'il
aille jusqu'au bout oui bien entendu
bien entendu qu'il y a eu une
obstruction mais si vous voulez le je
crois que on ne peut pas les mettre des
gens sur un monsieur un pied d'égalité
oui il y a eu une obstruction oui cette
obstruction est condamnable parce que le
le débat parlementaire doit justement se
faire dans la clarté or si vous posez si
vous déposez des amendements farfelus
qui ne se font qui ne font que répéter
évidemment c'est c'est pas clair et
c'est pas sincère donc oui les
oppositions une part de responsabilité
ça n'exonère pas le gouvernement d'avoir
utilisé
une comment dire tous les moyens qu'il
avait à sa disposition pour réduire le
le temps de le temps de débat
parlementaire pour venir est-ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure sur le Conseil
constitutionnel est-ce que pour vous les
critiques sur sa politisation sur son
manque supposé d'indépendance sont
fondées
écoutez ils sont pardon ils sont en
partie fondés ils sont en partie fondée
c'est à dire que le mode de nomination
des membres du Conseil constitutionnel
actuel constitue une exception
lorsqu'on est compare au mode de
nomination de la Cour constitutionnelle
allemande italienne espagnole belge bon
c'est une exception une exception
française et on peut effectivement être
critique à l'égard de ce mode de
nomination qui réserve aux autorités
politiques la désignation des membres du
conseil et qu'il ne posent pas de
conditions de compétences juridiques ou
et d'expérience juridique je dis pas
qu'il ne faut que des juristes au
Conseil constitutionnel je dis qu'il en
faut quand même pour parce que leur
boulot c'est justement de faire du droit
et pas de faire de la politique donc la
critique à l'égard du mode de
composition du Conseil constitutionnel
est pour moi légitime justifier par
rapport à ce qui se fait dans les autres
pays européens il ne faudrait plus
nommer d'hommes politiques qui n'est pas
de compétences juridique il ne faudrait
plus nommer d'anciens ministres comme
l'a fait Emmanuel Macron si on peut
nommer des anciens ministres mais il me
semble-t-il si je regarde ce qui se fait
dans les autres pays européens après un
délai de carence c'est-à-dire passer
directement de ministre un membre du
Conseil là problème mais
avoir été ministre et trois ans cinq ans
six ans après devenir membre du Conseil
constitutionnel pas de problème pourquoi
je dis en partie fondée parce que si je
prends l'histoire du du Conseil
constitutionnel et la grande décision du
Conseil puisque là on est peut-être à la
veille d'une grande décision alors les
grandes décisions du conseil c'est par
exemple la décision du 16 juillet 1971
le conseil à cette époque était présidé
par Gaston palevski gaulliste et le
Conseil était à majorité de demande
nommée par des autorités de droite bien
qu'a fait le Conseil constitutionnel de
16 juillet et bien il a annulé la
totalité de la loi voulue par Raymond
marchelin ministre et police qui avait
pour objet de soumettre la création
d'associations à l'autorisation
préalable de l'administration vous
rendez compte c'est pas rien nous étions
en 71 c'est à dire le Conseil était tout
petit à majorité gaulliste et pourtant
ils ont annulé la totalité de la loi qui
voulait soumettre autrement dit oui le
Conseil était composé de majorité de
droite à l'époque ça n'a pas empêché
d'annuler une loi qui avait été votée
par cette majorité égoïste nous sommes
en 2023 c'est le
président Badinter président du Conseil
constitutionnel avait cette formule les
membres du Conseil doit avoir à deux
voir d'ingratitude à l'égard des
personnes qui les ont nommées voilà il y
a une autre un autre sujet que va devoir
trancher le Conseil constitutionnel
aujourd'hui c'est la validation du
rythme du référendum d'initiative
partagée qui a été déposé par les
parlementaires de gauche des
parlementaires de gauche qui ont
redéposé un nouveau RIP hier pour
distillent sécuriser juridiquement le
premier vous comprenez cette démarche
pas du tout pourquoi pas du tout parce
que si vous voulez vous connaissez la
formule marquise vos beaux yeux d'amour
me font mourir vos beaux yeux Marquises
c'est non non le je pense qu'avec cette
deuxième
saisine
ils prennent un risque que le RIB qui a
été déposé le 20 mars soit retoqué et
que celui qu'il pose maintenant souhaite
également retoquer la loi actuelle
fixe un plancher qui est 62 ans ce qui
permet au Parlement d'aller au-delà
la proposition de du 20 mars 1962 c'est
de fixer un plafond
bon il s'agit bien d'une réforme puisque
on passe d'un plancher un plafond je ne
vois pas ce qu'apporte de plus puisque
vous me dites sécurisé
je ne vois pas ce comment oui oui je
veux pas en quoi ça s'écrit de passer de
si je dis bien là je régale de départ à
la retraite ne peut être fixée au-delà
de 62 ans c'est la proposition de mars à
il est interdit l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite supérieure à 62 ans c'est
quoi cette histoire je pense que là il y
a pas parce que c'est leur a pris mais
je pense
bien entendu il y a le nombre de
signatures s'apporte sur un objet social
et c'est une réforme j'ai mon collègue
Paul Cassia qui a fait une très belle
démonstration sur sur ce sujet et
les comment dire il n'y a pas eu de loi
promulguée sur les retraites de depuis
un an
mais est-ce que sur le plan parce que
Emmanuel Macron évidemment souhaite
tourner la page de la réforme des
retraites est-ce que sur le plan
institutionnel il a les outils pour
sortir de la crise où est-ce que ça ne
peut passer que par une solution
politique
il a les outils hypothèses
hypothèses la loi est censurée dans sa
totalité à ce moment-là les
manifestations s'arrêtent il faut
repartir à zéro et il entame des
négociations avec les dessins syndicats
et on
la réforme des retraites ne s'arrête pas
elle recommencera mais sur d'autres
bases le Conseil n'annule pas la loi le
président République promulgue et en
même temps la proposition référendaire
prospère est déclarée recevable ce qui
serait disons de mon point de vue
raisonnable politiquement et la
Constitution n'interdit pas d'être
raisonnable politiquement c'est que le
Président de la République
promulgue la loi mais suspendent son
application
jusqu'au terme de la procédure
référendaire
il n'y devrait pas c'est ce que Bruno Le
Maire avait fait d'ailleurs lorsqu'il y
avait eu la privatie de la loi qui
privatisait les aérodromes de de Paris
il y avait aussi une procédure
référendaire de lancer et l'application
de la loi qui privatise les zérodromes
avait été suspendus jusqu'au terme de la
campagne référendaire et puis aussi
ensuite à cause de l'état des marchés
financiers puisque vous rentrez dans la
période covid et finalement les
aérodromes de Paris n'ont jamais été
privatisés
si le conseil ne censure pas la loi
l'idée la plus raisonnable politiquement
et encore une fois c'est pas interdit
par la Constitution serait de suspendre
l'application de la loi jusqu'à la fin
du processus référendaire merci
Dominique merci beaucoup merci d'être
venu nous éclairer ce matin sur cette
décision du Conseil constitutionnel
qu'on connaîtra donc en fin de journée
merci beaucoup